americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 69
welcome to hannity this busy news friday
night 69 days americans held behind
enemy lines thousands of green card
holders siv applicants there are
families we have no idea the exact
number all suffering in silence under
taliban rule i know the rest of the
media and joe biden have quote turn the
page we won't do that many are already
dead but during last night's town hall
on fake news cnn joe biden didn't make a
single mention of afghanistan or the men
or the women and children and americans
and green card holders and allies he
abandoned after 13 days prior saying he
wouldn't do it not a mention not a
question not a word nothing wow
now it's possible joe doesn't even fully
remember what what happened in
afghanistan that's way back in august
and for him that's you know 400
lifetimes ago it was a whole three
months ago and let's face it joe biden's
not particularly doing well and that was
on display last night that he is
everything we've been telling you a
cognitive mess every day it seems to get
worse and worse it's scary it's not
funny anymore predictably last night
well the town hall became a train wreck
take a look
55 corporations for example in the
united states of america making over 40
billion dollars don't pay a cent
not a single little red cent you know if
you're in real estate major real estate
ask them they know they should be paying
a little more than 21
we can pay for this whole thing i
haven't written in a card here but i
won't bore you with the detail the
question was on the the on community
colleges
which which was a big campaign
promise that that you made you talked
about that on the campaign trail yeah
and i'm going to get it done
and if i don't i'll be sleeping alone
for a long time i'm going off to cop 26
in scotland uh and uh and i don't know i
guess it's two weeks or a week i'm
losing track of time 40 of all products
coming into the united states of america
on the west coast go through
uh los angeles and uh and uh um uh um
what am i doing here is it long beach
long beach thank you so
what i have said you're shaking your
head no but let me tell you something
jack it's the truth
uh uh well what am i doing here long
beach yeah yeah yeah thanks for the save
long beach at one point biden seemingly
forgot about his own hands and just
stood there
like this for an extended period of time
does anybody know what he was doing like
that what was that all about and of
course throughout the night biden
offered zero solutions for all of the
crisis that he himself had caused i have
solutions bring back the trump policies
on the border on energy on afghanistan
peace through strength on the economy
lower regulation lower taxes that all
work you know but according to joe's
spiking gas prices
they're not going to be getting better
any time soon and he blamed opec it's
not opec's fault it's your fault joe why
don't you call texas why don't you call
oklahoma north dakota alaska why don't
you hire back the keystone xl pipeline
workers you fired and maybe take back
that waiver you gave gave your friend
vladimir who pays you whose country pays
your son
millions with no experience you know
saying there's nothing i can do about
high gas prices wow that that's so
reassuring take a look
what about gas prices because sometimes
gas prices relate to
a foreign policy initiative that is
about something that goes beyond the
cost of gas and that's because of the
supply being withheld
by opec and so there's a lot of
negotiation that is
there
there's a lot of middle eastern folks
want to talk to me
i'm not sure i'm going to talk to them
do you have a timeline for gas prices
when you think they may start coming
down
my guess is you'll start to see gas
prices come down as we get by and going
into the winter i mean excuse me in the
next year in 2022 i don't see anything
that's going to happen in the meantime
it's going to significantly reduce gas
prices
the supply is not withheld by opec you
joe biden you artificially reduced the
supply of energy in the world because
you are married to the biden bernie new
green deal socialist
green new deal manifesto joe biden you
killed the keystone exile pipeline
you're making the hostile actor putin
rich again you're the one that banned
oil and gas exploration on all federal
lands you artificially reduced america's
and the world's oil and gas supply and
now the united states once again now
you're begging opec countries that hate
us for the lifeblood of our economy and
we're paying a buck 50 more a gallon and
paying more for every single thing we
buy and paying more to heat and cool our
homes under donald trump we were the
world's number one producer of oil and
gas for the first time in 75 years guess
what we were energy independent donald
trump at the end of his presidency
wasn't importing one single barrel from
saudi arabia now anymore instead of
begging texas why don't we make them i'd
rather ask you can ask texas you don't
even have to beg oklahoma alaska north
dakota they'll help you biden you're
blaming opec that is a cop-out and
frankly it's an all-out lie like most
everything else that comes out of your
mouth and according to the former ceo of
mcdonald's biden's oil and gas policies
are the cause core of
of inflation in the country and the
current supply chain fiasco the labor
shortage also is playing a huge role but
joe biden he is now vowing to make that
shortage even far worse
if he does what we're about to play and
it happens with nurses and teachers and
first responders and our military uh you
think the economy is bad now it will go
down precipitously right into the sewer
listen to joe
should police officers emergency
responders be mandated to get vaccines
and if not should they be
stay at home or let go yes and yes
[Applause]
oh fire them okay at this point i'll
take let's go brandon i'll take brandon
and the nascar driver over biden biden
went on to mock americans obsession with
freedom
wow now
is he going to do you're going to do
that joe is that going to do it just
spit in the faces of millions of
americans they're not going to listen to
you joe they're not going to listen to
flip-flop pouchy they're not going to
listen to the ever-changing you know
rules of the cdc or the nih you caused
this vaccine hesitancy all of you and by
the way because of that and because of
the mixed messaging and because of the
shifting change in changing standards
they've made up their own mind now you
can try to convince them but you've been
trying and it's not working and you now
you're going to fire them i thought you
said you'd never implement a mandate joe
fauci said it pelosi said it sake said
it you all said it wouldn't happen now
americans are being mandated what
happened to the choice of at least
getting tested
do you still offer them that option or
are you going to take away their their
pay their benefits their pensions
now of course the debate frankly in my
mind is over it's not no longer in this
country about vacs are not vacs because
millions of americans they have made up
their mind and they don't agree with joe
biden for whatever reason we've had that
debate that's their choice we live in a
free society and their decision now
there's got to be a way to thread the
needle because if you have all these
people willing to sacrifice their jobs
their pay their benefits their pensions
their careers their salaries over
mandates they must believe pretty
strongly in their position now make no
mistake thousands of cops firefighters
nurses first responders soldiers walking
off the job
if that happens this country will not be
more safe and secure and it'll have a
devastating impact on our economy joe
biden and his radical advisors do not
care about safety and security they only
care about politics just look at the
border in order to appease the radical
left joe biden not only is not enforcing
the laws of the land donald trump's
plans worked and he couldn't implement
them once again and they'll work once
again instead he's decided to go out on
his own and joe biden now where are we
we're now at a record high 40-year
record high of illegal immigrants coming
into the country ironically the same
time biden started construction of a
giant wall around his beach house by the
way it's going to cost you almost 500
grand now the southeastern border is a
disaster apprehensions are at an
all-time high we're on track for nearly
2 million
plus illegal immigrants this year and by
the way that's where 90 percent of of
heroin crosses into this country through
our southern border fentanyl is killing
hundreds of americans a week that's
crossing across the southern border joe
he's just too busy to visit so he lies
about visiting and says the
drive-through is a visit take a look
do you have plans to visit the southern
border i've been there before and i
haven't i mean i know it well i guess i
should go down but the
but the whole point of it is i haven't
had a whole hell of a lot of time to get
down i've been spending time
going around looking at the 900 billion
dollars worth of damage done by
uh by hurricanes and floods and and
weather and traveling around the world
but
i plan on now my wife jill has been down
she's been on both sides of the river
she's seen the circumstances there she's
looked into those places
this guy is a cognitive mess he's your
president wow i sent my wife down to
look at it and he never went there not
too busy to spend nearly every weekend
in delaware at your beach house right
joey and don't worry your borders are
kamala harris oh yeah she swung by el
paso once on her way to california while
she was spewing carbon emissions left
and right and of course she has no plans
to go back and by the way we you know
we've been looking at this for months we
can't find any record of joe biden ever
one time visiting the border jensaki got
into it again with our own peter ducey
and joe biden was definitely not lying
she says oh really what he did a
drive-by that counts as a visit to the
border
take a look
why did president biden say he has been
to the border
well peter uh as you may have seen
there's been a reporting that he
did drive through the border when he was
on the campaign trail in 2008. does that
count as a visit he said i've been there
before you're saying he drove by for a
few minutes does that count
what do you what is the root cause where
are people coming from who are coming to
the border peter the president said i'm
asking i'm asking you a question because
i think people should understand the
context where do people
i'll answer it for you people come from
central america and mexico to go to the
border there is a focus right now on a
photo op the president does not believe
a photo op is the same as solutions that
may be a difference he has with
republicans but that's not what he said
either he said i guess i should go down
so does he think that he needs a photo
op is that what he's saying he doesn't
and that's a fundamental disagreement he
has
all right the white house has any
evidence that biden actually stopped and
visited the southern border we'd love to
see it they're lying and if joe biden
had a solution to the southern border
crisis we'd like to hear about that
here's the thing they don't have and
that is a solution i have one follow the
trump plan they're not working on a
solution they don't care what happens at
the border and tonight they're focused
on one thing above all else new green
deal radical socialism packaged in this
build back better propaganda talking
points and bumper stickers this bill is
a massive step of america the greatest
wealth creating system in the entire
history of mankind now becoming a
socialist hell hole you know like the
former soviet union venezuela cuba okay
simply put it takes money from everybody
that works and gives it to everyone else
that is confiscation of pretty much all
all of the economy in the form of
fairness and government entitlements the
bill raises taxes on everyone especially
those making under 50 grand a year joe's
lying on that too it will increase both
the debt and deficit on a massive scale
even though they lie and say it won't
cost a single penny inflation which is
already really bad is going to get worse
the bill will replace reliable forms of
energy you know like uh oil and gas and
coal with unreliable costly forms of
energies you know oh windmills and solar
panels that are not proven reliable if
joe manchin if you really care about the
people of west virginia and i believe
you do you will vote no on any form of
this bill